many of us have hobbies that we really
enjoy but life always seems to get in
the way and for me that is writing I've
been writing since I was a kid I
absolutely enjoy stories and I've been
writing a short Dark Fantasy Novella and
um I am rapidly running out of time to
get a new chapter together for my
writing group so I thought today I would
just run off into the Wilderness live
out my dreams and write on my own
surrounded by trees I thought I would
share this experience with you let's see
how many words I can get done and let's
see how scary it really is to go on a
solo trip alone in the woods
I have arrived
um I don't know if you can hear that but
that is a sound of rain and weather
warning level wins the wins were crazy
today
I have picked a day to come but you know
I'm not mad at it because
the weather of the book that I'm writing
is Autumn and that's not exactly sunny
and nice anyway camera keep me in
focused please
so
yeah I guess I will unpack and we'll see
how these next couple of days go
vegetables
um
on this trip I wanted to take a few
books to inspire me and the first was
the Encyclopedia of things that never
were which is basically the best
bestiary I have ever come across I'd
really recommend this book the second
are the first four books from the
Earthsea series I'm currently on the
third book the second is my favorite so
far though and it's a really good
fantasy series and what's a fantasy
getaway without some J.R.R Tolkien so
here is my very special version of the
similarion this copy is very dear to me
it's got some beautiful illustrations on
it so I'm gonna place it down really
carefully and take good care of it
foreign
this place has a really nice Lookout
it's where you can just see over fields
and stuff and if you're lucky I will
take you there tomorrow morning but now
it is half past seven I think it's time
for me to make some dinner
and maybe start thinking about doing
some writing about time
um I'm kind of cheating I I bought this
itsu thing
and it's just vegetables and hot water
but I bought my own vegetables to also
add to them as well so I'm just gonna
get this crack in and um make some food
um
how does this work
water fell for the mound side
starting from Pops of Shamrock Moss it
weaved its way around foliage of
marigolds and Crimson before falling
into a hidden stream below that etched
its way through the mud
looking into the water celentina saw a
Darkness so deep that she almost mistook
it for a sheer drop to a nothingness
blow if it had not been for a handful of
small ripples that gave way to its true
nature
yet no reflection did offer our
protagonist this night like a ghostly
path it wounds slightly to silentiness
left before Vanishing completely into
the belly of the giant through a mouth
so large that it pierced the clouds
cover Jagged Stones sat like Teeth upon
its roof and from deep inside sealantina
could Source the sound of the shallow
breathing
and with it the sweet song
Darkness followed her from all sides now
as the sun took its rest for the day
calling its rays that played a top stray
water droplets to follow it below the
hillside until the red sank to ashes
fear creeped Upon A shivering sealantina
from the darkness as it often does to
those caught alone it
yet despite this her curiosity pulled
her toward the comfort of the song that
rang from the open mouth of the cave
until finally guided only by sound
see what he has stepped upon stone
ground
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hello this is uh
jagmonics reporting from upon Yonder
Tree Shop
no good morning last night I basically
read over what I'd written uh in my
previous chapter just to get myself up
scratch with where I am
because I'm about eight chapters in now
starting my eighth chapter
and I've taken a good long break maybe
about two months work has just caught up
with me you know how it go
and um yeah I just haven't had a chance
to do any work on it so I needed that
evening just to kind of reacquaint
myself with the story the protagonist
where she's going next I've got bullet
points of what I want to get done for
chapter eight
let's see if I can get at least 2 000
words or more
hopefully more
um definitely being surrounded by the
forest is making me feel inspired
because right now in my story she is in
the middle of a forest and she's
actually come across a cave but she's in
the forest I feel like it's really
important to find time for the for the
things that make you happy even if it
doesn't necessarily make you money I
know money is always the end goal for a
lot of us because we gotta pay bills and
we gotta buy food but I think
what is what is the point of living life
if you're not doing something that
you're passionate about or that makes
you happy and inviting stories has
always been something always been
something I've been doing
and even if I'm not doing it as my job
that doesn't mean that I'm not good
enough
to attempt to write a book
and also it's not about being good it's
just about doing something that you feel
fulfills you usually that's where the
best stuff comes from I find
because it's relatable in some way
definitely am I a protagonist shares
some of my struggles
she is a
wannabe
Bard musician poet thing but she can't
play music she can only sing and that's
kind of how I feel most of the time
but I don't live in a weird medieval
fantasy land where a woman aren't
allowed to be musicians so that's
different
and also there aren't magical beings but
hey actually maybe there are who knows
I like to keep my mind open I should
probably go back in make a cup of coffee
and um
have some breakfast
start writing
[Applause]
wow
foreign
[Music]
home is behind
the world I had
hair and their Harmony
pass to trust
[Music]
are all alive
foreign
[Music]
no it's light cool I have tried to work
outside twice and the first time it
started hailing the second time just now
it started thundering which is cool but
then I see this like big black cloud I'm
like yeah that's not cool and then it
thunders so loud that the whole little
Hut starts to shake
I'm kind of hoping I can get it again on
camera but I I don't know if it'll
happen again
but it was cool
I love it
um but yeah it's a shame that I can't
get to work outside but that's fine so
it's 2PM and I've written
700 words around about
it's not really that many
goal was like 2 000 I think I'm getting
distracted by like the weather the birds
squirrels
you I'm getting distracted by you and
the camera I did also do a bit
[Music]
either did you hear that please say the
mic pick that up
still going I can feel it
through the floorboards it's shaking the
little Hut I need I need to stop getting
distracted and work if I could do
another like 600 words before dinner
I think we'd be golden so let's uh
let's try and just get in the flow shall
we we're reaching high and wide across
the lake so that its leaves swear like
golden hair and the salty Breeze it's
Roots web the surface of the small bit
of Earth and stood there
no and and there stood amongst The Well
of shore
stood to the figure celentina had
glimpsed in the woods
it was singing
yeah I think I need to put it there
beneath the canopy of trees
lays the shell of a great Beast
no danger dotted group
oh it's eyes are closing sleep
cradled By the Waters arms
held within a state of car
no I will not shut up this is my time I
paid for this
[Music]
everybody
I just remembered that's my grandma's
funeral song
[Music]
hello
it is
um
after dinner time what time is it ten
past seven and uh
I'm gonna write
how is it going so far
it's good
I just wish I had more time here I'm on
almost a thousand four hundred words
which is good because I was hoping to
get around about 2 000 and who knows
maybe I'll get more than that I've got
tonight and then tomorrow morning
so I've got a little bit more time it
would be nice to have like a day to
settle in a place
and then another day but then I probably
want another day and then another day
another day so
yeah it has been really nice though one
thing I don't think I've shared with you
is that I'm trying not to go on like
social media I don't have very much
internet here anyway when I feel a bit
bored or like I want a break I'm not
just going on to Instagram or YouTube
like I will normally do I
pick up my guitar or just listen to the
birds
uh I did watch some YouTube while eating
dinner but I think that's allowed
um but yeah I feel like it's made me a
much more productive person because it's
kept my mind in the mindset of writing
and where I'm at and the story and just
constantly ruminating over where I want
to go with the story I'm very lucky that
I'm completely alone here
uh it's nice not to have any
distractions from anyone else especially
I'm a very verbal writer and it is so
nice to like walk around the space and
just talk about my story to myself just
to see if
you see if sense I think I have clips
that you've seen but I like to put a lot
of poetry and singing into my stories so
I need to say that out loud and start
singing it to make sure that it sounds
good you know it's gonna be and it's
it's just you it just floats
um but anyway enough procrastination
I should probably write some more I'm
gonna write some more and then I might
put on my little hobbit fire stove it's
called a hobbit stove how cute is that
and then um
yeah
let's see how I do
so this is it end of a journey
I've written words
but how many
I actually was on quite a roll last
night
um and I got over two thousand
so I reached my goal
but how much more over
I can't remember I think it was like
2100 or something but I still have time
to write today I am so close to
finishing this chapter I'm going to do a
little bit more writing in a second
um I don't know when to address this
but I know I might possibly
be putting somewhere in this thumbnail
or something that I hit like 10 000 and
I'm not gonna specify that that's
characters not words
um I just think it'd be nice clickbaity
title but just to explain about that I
wholeheartedly believe
that when you do something for fun when
you do something as a hobby because it
fulfills you because you feel like
you're giving a part of your Soul or
being to it a piece of art
it does not matter how much you get done
um whether you meet like a hard goal or
not I really think it's quality over
quantity I know some people can write
like 2 000 words every day no problem
I am not one of those people and
hopefully maybe you've seen why because
I get very distracted with like poetry
and singing and I just love reading my
story out in my head before I even get
it down on paper and that's
a little slow process at times
um
change that because I think if I did it
any other way then it wouldn't be a
story that that I fall in love with or
that I'm excited about and it probably
wouldn't be as good because I really
feel like when you read something out
loud it just
I don't know just cements whether it
feels right
it's hard to explain what I'm trying to
say is it's good to set yourself goals
and deadlines
but
it doesn't always matter if you hit
those exact goals
as long as you're doing something that
feels rewarding for you and making time
for it that is the main thing and I
could sit here and say yeah I forced
myself to write Ten Thousand Words
they'd probably be ten thousand words of
poop and I'd much rather have 2 000
whatever I have after this next little
writing session
words of stuff that I can be proud of
time for a coffee and to write a bit
more and then we gotta leave
but I'll let you know the exact final
word count don't you worry
many hours has passed before celentina
found herself resting upon the ancient
Tomlin Stone
arms flayed within its carved hole that
was once used many moons ago as an
ancient marriage ritual
it was said that if you joined hands
through the hole and sang the proper
incantations then the protector of the
forest would bless thee to form a bond
as strong as that of water and wind
this power would vary season to season
with most preferring the lady of spring
whose name none can pronounce but who
deals in giving life a new and healing
wounds afresh passing the guardian Stone
once more celentina bowed slowly hoping
she would not offend it by taking in a
creature of the forest
then she walked toward the dim glow of
houses whose fires crackled their last
Embers and avoided the snores of the
town drunk which echoed throughout the
streets
so now I am back from my writing Retreat
and I already miss it
um I'm really proud of myself with the
amount of words that I was able to write
but also just at how I felt during the
whole process I'll probably put some
sort of click-baked thumbnail like I
wrote this many words where are we but
really it's not about how much I wrote
it's about making time for myself and
doing things that make me happy why I
wanted to share this on my channel
because I know it is very very different
from my usual Unreal Engine and Game Dev
related content is because I believe we
should all feel able to create just for
the simple enjoyment of creating I think
in this capitalist Society we often feel
like we can't spend time on something
unless it's going to amount in some sort
of money or for some sort of beneficiary
purpose I completely understand why
because cost of living has gone up here
in England and I know in many other
countries it's really difficult as well
but I do feel it's so important to allow
yourself to create for the simple
enjoyment of creating to allow yourself
to create for you and you alone maybe
not even to share it with other people
and particularly not to make money off
it not everyone has the means to get
away to the forest for a weekend I
completely understand that but being
able to switch off from social media we
can all do that being able to tell
yourself tonight I am going to spend
time on this hobby that I love because I
love it and that's it
hopefully we can all find some time to
do that so tell me down in the comments
below what is a hobby that you would
love to dedicate some time to and I
really hope you managed to find the time
to do that a massive thank you to my
patreons who knew this video was coming
uh quite far in advance actually so I
really hope you all enjoyed it thank you
for your ongoing support it really means
so very much to me and best of luck with
all your creative projects I know this
was a different video I think I've
already said that but I hope you enjoyed
the calming Vibes of me in the forest
writing my book more Unreal Engine
tutorial videos coming very soon don't
you worry have a lovely day or evening
and I'll see you very soon bye
this is funny nice because I used to do
things
by myself a lot I went to Germany up by
myself
um
I went other places by myself and I
haven't really taken myself on a solo
trip in such a long time mainly because
covered kind of locked everyone down for
ages and then I got kind of like social
anxiety pretty badly
um but now I feel like I'm working
through all that and I'm able to now go
out on my own
I just love it I'm loving it